the problem that we've got is that we
are now entering I think the tenth week
of industrial action and
we have been coping reasonably well with
each one of the kind of days of this
industrial action through a combination
of Planning by Health leaders an
agreement about the trade unions to
maintain life and limb cover and also
the public using the Health Service Less
on those strike days and the danger is
that because we cope with these
individual days we're not realizing the
the damage that is being caused below
the surface so with the most intensive
week of strike action the health service
has seen coming up next week we we spoke
to our leaders and asked them
the impacts they're concerned about and
number one is that the recovery that
we're starting to see in the health
services at risk so we have seen real
progress in the last few weeks few uh
shorter ambulance delays uh making
inroads into those waiting lists we're
still confident uh that by the spring no
one will be waiting more than 18 months
for an operation but our leaders are
saying that that recovery that recovery
in terms of operations getting urgent
Emergency Care back on track that is
jeopardized if we continue to see these
strikes uh unfold so that's the first
issue is is is that the recovery is in
under threat but there are other
challenges as well we're concerned about
uh the the public holding back because
while we're grateful for any support
from the public as NHS England said
yesterday if the public needs to come to
the NHS if you have got a problem
because otherwise those issues get
stored up in the community
so what we can't have is just as
protracted kind of War of Attrition it
is having an effect and that effect will
worsen as the strikes worsen which is
why it is once again
we're calling on the government to find
a way to reopen negotiations on the
trade unions to enter negotiation and
try to stop this industrial action
continuing
I spoke to the BMA this morning and they
told me they thought it was likely that
Junior doctors would also vote to walk
out they're being balloted at the moment
what added pressure do you think that
would put on the Health Service if
Junior doctors walked out to
no well that would be another huge blow
another huge challenge for the Health
Service uh to cope with we're already
seeing on Monday for the first time
combined Stripes ambulance strikes
nurses strikes on the same day so you
know this is an escalating and
deteriorating situation Junior doctors
would really certainly intensify it but
even without the junior doctors as I say
there is an impact we've seen in nearly
11 000 operations canceled nearly 90 000
appointments canceled and that's before
next week adds to this
and another thing I'd want to say is
that you know there's a lot of talk
quite rightly about the NHS modernizing
reforming we we saw the other day an
announcement of a major roll out of of
hospital at home using technology to
enable people to get care in their own
homes it's very difficult for managers
to innovate and reform when they're
spending their time you know rewriting
rotors trying to think about how to cope
with these these strike days
in Wales Welsh NHS staff have suspended
strike action following an improved
offer from ministers there are you
encouraged At All by that
I I think in the sense that it is clear
that in a sense whatever side you're on
in this dispute it is only if government
is willing to reopen negotiation about
pay this year that we're going to see
any movement the trade unions have made
clear that they won't enter negotiation
unless that's on the table
so I think it does you know it does
depend on the government being willing
to take that first step that's what
we're calling for again obviously it
requires the trade unions to be
pragmatic and realistic as well but
until the government takes that first
step of being willing to reopen
negotiation on this year's pay
settlement it's difficult to see any
progress and and so these strike days
continue
um with this impact which is often hard
to see but is growing under the surface
and as we say those strikes across the
NHS set to begin on Monday the RCN the
nurses Union has said in the wake of the
the progress that appears to be made in
Wales they've urged the government to
reopen talks as I understand it Downing
Street has said that there's no talks
planned for this weekend so what is your
message to them
well all we can do and and what we're
saying today is the result of having
spoken to our leaders in detail last
week is to point out the consequences of
that and you know I understand the
pressures on the government in terms of
public spending industrial action taking
place across the public sector but
ministers have also emphasized the
incredible importance of getting the NHS
back on its fee of recovering from the
winter crisis that that we were in of
making inroads into those waiting lists
and and the government's going to have
to make choices because unless it's
willing to find a way of reopen
negotiation then that recovery that was
just seeing the first signs of it and
it's something to be you know really
pleased about given where we were a few
weeks ago but that recovery will be at
risk